c'était un verdict attendu par tout un
peuple
au bout de six ans de procès le tribunal
spécial pour le liban le tsl a mis fin à
un feuilleton libanais qui dure depuis
le 14 février 2005
la chambre de première instance est
d'avis que la syrie et le hezbollah
avait peut-être des motifs d'éliminer
monsieur hariri et certains de ses
alliés politiques
toutefois rien n'indique que les
dirigeants du hezbollah étaient
impliqués dans le meurtre de monsieur
hariri et il n'y a aucune preuve directe
de l'application de la syrie dans ce
meurtre
quinze ans après la mort du premier
ministre rafic hariri dans un attentat
qui aura coûté la vie à 21 autres
personnes
un seul des quatre accusés salim ayyash
membres du hezbollah a été reconnu
coupable
la famille et les proches de rafic
hariri 10 accepter le verdict rendu par
le tribunal
[Musique]
le tribunal a statué et au nom de la
famille de l'ancien premier ministre
rafic hariri et au nom des familles des
martyrs et victimes nous acceptons la
décision du tribunal je pense que le
verdict a été transparent et que tous
ceux qui ont accusé le tribunal était
politisé mais ce n'était pas le cas
parce qu'avant dont reconnaître coupable
salim ayyash il y en avait 4 et
maintenant il est le seul à avoir été
condamnée alors je pense que c'était
juste pour tout le monde et dans les
rues de beyrouth
les réactions sont mitigées
ce n'est pas un verdict normal cela fait
14 ans que nous attendons la vérité et
jusqu'à présent ils ne nous ont pas
donné la vérité vraie il cache des
choses
et dès que vous vous retournez il ya
quelque chose de différent et à la fin
ils disent que ça ne concerne personne
dans le pays alors qu a fait exploser le
port de beyrouth
tout le monde dit que ce n'était pas
nous c'est incroyable ça ne vaut rien
ils enquêtent depuis 15 ans chaque fois
qu'il fournisse des preuves
il n'ya jamais sans preuves décisives
contre eux pendant quinze ans ils ont
pris de l'argent pour rien juste pour
créer une autre guerre civile au liban
ni plus ni moins tous les noms ont déjà
été lié au hezbollah
demain il y aura une guerre civile
confessionnelle ici ils vont en profiter
je ne veux pas commenter le verdict
c'est mieux qu'est ce que je pourrais
dire après quinze ans ils ont choisi un
seul gars pour porter le chapeau pour
tous c'est tout c'est une blague
le verdict est une blague de son côté le
hezbollah par la voix de son chef hassan
nasrallah a fait savoir avant le procès
et que le groupe n'était pas concerné
par le verdict du tsl le hezbollah
continuera donc à croire en l'innocence
de son membres condamnés